uh so I'm Jessica Sedin I am a senior
fellow at the Yale Jackson School of
global Affairs and I am very happy to
have been invited to chair the last
panel of the day which is always kind of
a daunting um thing on a day that also
starts at 8:30 and involves as many
papers and difficult topics and thoughts
and possibilities as as these sessions
have I'm also the Jessica who was
invoked in the beginning of the session
as um saying that the climate emergency
is here now um I'm not going to revise
that I'm just going to add a little
addendum I think what's happening uh
when you start to look at some of the
the growing pile of scientific evidence
is that we have an unfolding likely
accelerating set of environmental
changes that include but go Way Beyond
temperature rainfall and sea level rise
um these are changes that we have an
increasingly well grounded uh bounded
understanding of we have an
understanding of some of the
nonlinearities and also a great sense of
what we don't understand about how those
are going to affect the infrastructure
Services economic setup that we have
Ecuador right now is having rolling
blackouts it's a highly Hydro electric
depend in economy um and El Nino has not
been so great for hydroelectricity
that's a little bit out of bounds from
what's happened historically um these
are the kinds of things that we can from
the science side anticipate at the same
time on The Human Side it's pretty clear
that we're a species that is not passive
um that is entirely capable of
responding to very significant changes
both local Regional and Global sometimes
we're self-interested often we're venal
we sub suffer from moral hazard and I
think some of the papers have
highlighted uh frictions that are deeply
social in how we adapt to these changes
but we know these things these two sides
these two streams of Knowledge from very
large intellectual Enterprises both on
the climate science and climate impacts
modeling on the one side and then also
from economics and more broadly social
science understanding of foundations I
think we have an enormous amount of
knowledge about the first principles the
Dynamics of environmental change on the
one side the Dynamics of human responses
on the other our challenge going ahead
is how do we put these two streams
together more effectively um how do we
better combine these this understanding
of the micro to maybe meso foundations
to build an understanding and a sense
sense of uh ability to make some of the
trade-offs that we need to make now uh
use of scarce resources Now versus later
this versus that here versus there um
what are some of the narratives the
balance urgency but also recognize
agency and adaptation in anticipating
costs most importantly and for me what
are some of the ways that a combined
stream
of understanding the climate dynamic
very very well at higher resolution and
the human social dynamics at higher
resolution what does that say what does
that tell us about interventions policy
instruments investments in information
investments in credible information the
the kinds of Institutions we might need
to create social tipping points to
respond to the environmental and climate
tipping points that are increasingly
unfortunately looking within looking Pro
more looking more probable um I think
with that that that Enterprise is both
an intellectual one it's a research
agenda but it's also in some ways an
Institutional one in how how we organize
interdisciplinary conversations
interdisciplinary research agendas and
spaces for framing the questions setting
agendas talking about how we represent
humans in climate models and climate in
human models
and for that we have the next hour um to
figure all that stuff out but Lo luckily
we have an excellent panel um I'll
introduce them in a second and ask them
to come up for some opening remarks but
I just wanted to also say one other
thing just to set expectations about
this is this is also a bit of a tortured
panel uh we have an hour uh an hour and
10 minutes left hour and 15 minutes and
what I've asked the panelists to do um
in kind of design thinking mode is give
give opening remarks on what they in
their work experience what they in their
their their research and their practice
as policy makers and as people who have
been engaging in interdisciplinary
conversations um what they see as gaps
in combining the human side and the
climate side and then we'll have a
discussion of some of those gaps then
we'll come back for five long relatively
longer remarks from each of the panelist
on what can we do to resolve some of
these gaps hopefully looking at the
problem first then responding with
Solutions will lead us to some ideas
that wouldn't have occurred to the four
panelists
um just coming in fresh so we're we're
hoping to have um that kind of
discussion and at the end leave some
time for Q&A so I want to introduce the
panel first um and I'll call them up one
by one but I'm going to introduce
everybody now so you can see where
people or anticipate maybe where people
are coming from everybody's bios
are in the um are in the uh on the
conference program but uh our first
speaker will be Tony Smith who is a
professor of economics and chair of the
department at Yale his research is
mostly looking at uh global economy
climate models with high Geographic
resolution or that's his that's his most
recent Focus so I'm anticipating that
he'll come with with perspectives from
building those our second speaker will
be Regina Rodriguez who is a professor
of physical oceanography and climate at
uh the um University of Santa Katarina
Federal University of Santa Katarina in
Brazil um she co-chairs the world
climate research program Atlantic region
panel and marit Marine heat waves
research Focus she's also a co-principal
investigator of my climate risk which
she'll tell you a bit more about third
speaker is uh Pierce Forster who's
professor of climate physics and the
founding director of the pr is the
International Center for climate at
University of Leeds he's also the
interim chair for the UK climate change
committee he's known for his work on
radiative forcing climate sensitivity
and has been a lead or contributing lead
author for the fourth fifth and sixth
ipcc reports as well as the 2018 special
warming report on special uh Special
Report on global warming of 1.5° C so um
and and our fourth speaker Tel Kar who
gets the prize for being up the latest
of all of us because it's 3:30 a.m.
where she is now will be coming in by
Zoom um is an associate professor at the
National Institute advanced studies in
Bangalore India also an ipcc author and
her work uh has been looking at Equity
within the general Enterprise of climate
modeling so I think we've got a great
panel um coming from different
perspectives hopefully between all of us
we can describe describe some of the
gaps and solve some of them with further
Ado I'll turn it over to Tony for um
five minute opening remarks
thanks thanks a lot for including me in
this um in this Workshop today and this
conference it's been a fascinating a
long but uh fascinating and also
stimulating day I've quite enjoyed it um
so I have a have a um I couldn't I
didn't want to risk not having slides so
I have one slide with words and two
pictures but are those going to can I
just go ahead the clicker should work
right okay got it it should all be yep
and I have the same problem everyone
else is
having okay oh no you're going backwards
sorry
yeah there we go all right there I am
all right so um so this is my one slide
with words so what I've been working on
I I I'm a macroeconomist by training and
have worked on heterogeneous agent
models of the macroeconomy with
heterogeneity across households and uh
since parlayed that
methodological uh those methodological
skills into building or attempting to
build high resolution integrated
assessment models so the idea here is to
build computational Laboratories for
evaluating the effects of climate change
at a high degree of resolution
geographically and in particular what
I've been working on most recently is to
merge Earth system models with Dynamic
General equilibrium economic models to
incorporate in particular weather and
extreme events as well as climate so
it's called two-way coupling the
literature I think I'm partly on this
panel too because I am working with two
climate scientists on this this coupling
that we're working on uh Trudy Selmo
used to be here at Yale and that's where
I met her and now she's in Norway and it
turns out she's a co-author with Pierce
forer on part of the ipcc report I just
learned today and and one of her
students so we're working together
trying to integrate these two models and
this next point is a little bit a point
more for climate scientists but there a
more economists here and fewer climate
scientists maybe but we're trying to
build a fully articulated what we call a
structural model that spells out the
behavior of the climate system and how
it interacts with the economy and how
agents behave and how they respond to to
various policies that might be designed
to address climate change so we can look
at uh quanti the effects of
counterfactual policies and ask
questions like how do resources move
across space uh how that's space spatial
adaptation seems critical here who gains
and who loses and once you have a model
like this you can then ask questions
about uh doing you know a detailed
quantitative analysis of international
climate agreements or International
sharing of climate risk so I'll just
show my my one picture this is just an
example this actually looks a lot like
pictures that we've seen today although
it's coming from very different set of
methodologies and tools without going
into details uh this is showing a
counterfactual experiment in a model
calibr of the global economy um showing
who gains and who Lo loses from a a a
uniform tax on carbon these are
percentages of consumption per year so
basically places that are already hot or
are are losing uh so sorry places that
are already hot like a carbon tax they
want to slow down warming and they're
gaining so that's just subsaharan Africa
that's that's Saharan Africa Russia uh
is actually losing from a carbon tax
because they're cold and would like to
warm a bit so we've actually seen this
picture several times today I think um
another thing we can do is look at
inequality say so we have this the
model's actually broken into 19,000
little regions so each
um each I'm experiencing what other
people have experienced so um each each
each agent is a little is a is a region
um sorry each agent is a little region
so 19,000 of these and interact them
through markets through uh they make
consumption saving decisions Ander
decisions uh they respond to tax policy
they they interact through Capital
markets and they interact through the
through the global climate system um all
right so once we have this model then I
can I can ask you know what what how
will inequality change over time so this
is showing across this is GDP uh uh uh
per capita by country not region
aggregated to countries you can see the
90 9010 percentiles in measure of
inequality it starts at 30 and and
according to my model increases to
around 46 that's the Top Line the second
line shows what happens in an optimal
tax and this model actually doesn't
change things very much but the point is
that you can you can run this
counterfactual experiment all right so
what I would say um we need so getting
to my last that's sort of where I'm
coming in what I'm doing uh the
challenges that I face or uh at faces is
working across disciplines it's just
getting that conversation going
understanding how an earth System model
runs and then teaching the climate
scientists how my economic model runs
and why I need to think about
forward-looking Behavior say and I think
the more we can get people together like
in rooms like this and get interaction
going the more we can build more
plausible and interesting models so I
would say we need micro and
macroeconomists we need climate
scientists we need ecologists
geographers um and you know a number of
the papers today like Valerie's paper
and then
um the paper on Jakarta that Allan just
gave uh papers this morning all those
all those papers can maybe inform the uh
the macro model that I'm building and
then next what I think we really need in
this space is powerful Computing
resources and and Technical expertise on
uh numerical analysis and coding to to
solve these Models All right so I think
I'm done I will stop stop there all
right it's my five minutes
okay um we have in the order sorry I
have to come to the mic uh in the order
dictated by the slides um de we have
well we have Regina is our next speaker
um also uh just as a as a background for
these opening remarks the ask was where
are you coming where do you come from uh
in terms of your past research and what
is the what are the types of problems
that you see so hopefully we'll get some
common ities and some convergences over
to
you hi um um thank you I would like to
thank you Jessica for inviting me and so
I'm as as she said I'm a climate
scientist from Brazil and uh I work uh
particularly with climate uh variability
and Extremes in South America a region
has been uh exposed to many hazards uh
lately as you can see
as you can uh know and I realized that
most of the climate information
generated by scientists uh was UN
reaching the people the most need uh
Society H this is a perspective from uh
obviously climate scientists and climate
information and mainly in the global
South and in order to reduce their uh
vulnerability increase uh uh the
resilience um so um Jessica ask us to
say uh what we think that is the big
gaps and in in in our case for the kids
there has been a call for usable or
actionable climate information yet
despite this a awareness and Global
effort it's widely accepted that there
is a significant Gap uh between the
production and the use of climate
information and I argue that the Gap
results in part from us climate
scientist focus on better data and
models rather than better decision
making
so it's going really fast this okay well
uh we generally use a top down as a
climate scientist approach that adopts a
disciplinary uh based uh measures of
scientific quality the problem is that
even if user informed uh such a top down
approach is inevitably drive driven by
us climate scientists themselves and
that does violate the core um principle
of co-production of this climate
information so
um sorry um so our traditional uh uh
um that's where I wanted to read so our
traditional ways of prod uh producing
aggregate climate information can leave
climate scientists empty handed for many
regions of the world uh particularly in
the global South for ex for example this
figure from the last ipcc report
aggregated all the information from data
and models described in L literature to
identify if there has been changes in
precipitation leading to agricultureal
or ecological drought but they did this
exercise for other uh uh uh aspects uh
and you can see the regions for uh for
which there is limited data or
literature on past change are showing
gray with low agreement on the type of
change uh showing hatching and all with
low confidence in a human contribution
to those change due to limited evidence
is uh showing open is typing ising and
we can see that vast areas of the global
map are is still gray hatched or with
open EST stapling this is due to the
limited long-term data records or poor
representation of climate models uh of
the relevant uh physical processes
behind extreme events and the ambiguous
model prediction of the forced response
to climate change for those region Main
in the global South again yet there can
be a wealth of local climate knowledge
if you look to the chapter 10 and U um
um that is ignored when we try to do
this agregation so my last thing that I
want to say that is then uh climate
change science as its current practice
tends to frame the scientific questions
as singular definitive ones it does this
by FX on projections uh from climate
models
H and emphasize where there is consensus
among them acknowledging uncertainty but
not actually exploring it uh the focus
of a singular definitive problem is also
expressed in a still common practice uh
across most public published climate uh
change science to interpret statistical
significance in a dous true false Manner
and avoided the articulation of a
multiple possible hypothesis which would
allow a plural conditional uh framing of
[Applause]
uncertainty okay well it's been a very
interesting day today so I'll tell you
where I come from so I'm
a climate scientist uh and I spent a
long time just trying to make the best
possible projections of the average
surface surface surface temperature
and if you look at the IPC report ipcc
report from last time we were able to
make a significant change from what
we've done before we we have
this
simple of physical climate model
emulator that we are able to kind
calibrate with a more sophisticated ones
uh and in particular for the ipcc report
we were also able to calibrate it to the
observation and be able to calibrate it
with
good physical understanding from the
different chapters of the ipcc report
and we were able to put the lines of
evidence together to be able to con
really constrain our surface temperature
projection for the first time uh uh and
and by doing this we were able to
exclude some
possible very high surface temperature
projections so so for for your Economist
doing all your kind of kind of kind of
kind of Fisk analyses that should be a
fantastic thing to be able to include uh
and it is really encouraging that this
this model has been taken up by your
community I've heard the bill
n how
is now included in
his
T model I mean I'm sure he's a fantastic
Economist but he's not a good climate
modeler and the actual kind climate
modeling component was a bit well well
I'm not going to say anything I mean
he's a great guy so but but but anyway
so he had replaced it by the one that we
had which is
great and this is the one that would all
so that
the United States government do use to
calculate their social cost of carbon
with so that's
fantastic but uh uh and I absolutely
appreciate the
citations but but I would appreciate far
more than that the
conversations and interesting that was
that was done without talking to us so
so and it's only people like us that
really we really comprehend understand
or
the assumptions that kind of after go
into the calculations
um uh uh uh and I think far more than
the just the conversations as well I'd
appreciate that can change as well that
that of course the projection depends on
the like the thing that you guys know
like the GDP and the popula changes and
all the other things and it would be
good to be able to work out the way they
interact by the conversations um and
as chessica said at the end of her
introduction I have recently become a
polit politician and it's very
interesting that you you can give
governments the
best evidence package very well but they
don't necessarily do anything with that
and I and we haven't got a lot of time
uh uh uh uh and but but I I think we get
to act together as a community we we
sort of can do things so the inflation
reduction Act was a good opportunity
example where the are the instances and
I you now know in my new position that I
suddenly get a telephone call from
number 10 and they say please can you
think there something to do you
know so are the
opportunity and I think if we as the
community have that sense ofcy to affect
change uh I think we can try and do
things a bit
differently
um so while we're while we're switching
the screen over to our fourth panelist
Tel kard who's joining us from Bangalore
I just wanted to highlight one thing
that pierce mentioned which is we're the
ones who know the assumptions underneath
this um and I think that may be one of
the focal points for the kinds of
conversations and the conversation space
that we can have uh let me know when
you're up there Tel for opening remarks
thank you Jessica and it's been great
listening to all the interventions
throughout the day well um it's been
throughout the night for me since but
since there's very little time let me
jump right into it uh I'm going to speak
about the macro models uh especially the
integrated assessment models or the IM
AMS some of the first of which in fact
came from the Department of Economics at
Hil of course um you know I'm very
grateful to Piers for being sufficiently
provocative so that I sound I may sound
less so um
the S the IMs have become the dominant
modeling tool for projecting social
economic and related energy use Trends
uh into the future the sixth assessment
report of the ipcc depends quite heavily
on these IMS while there are a range of
discussions uh in the ipcc reports about
um you know a lot of other things uh the
summary for you the global model
scenarios from the IMs
disproportionately dominate uh the
summary for policy makers which are then
further even more disproportionately
picked up by the media and then even
more distilled and used without the
accompanying context very often um in uh
cop decisions right so both cop 26 and
cop 27 for example quote the number of
43% reductions in GG emissions which
corresponds to the median of all Global
scenarios assessed by the ipcc uh for
the 1.5 degre Celsius Target so it's
become a prescription for policy and so
it it becomes important to analyze this
my work uh focuses on questions of
equity and Justice in modeling burden
sharing models as well as other kinds of
models um so the you know I'm not going
to go into the details of what the IMs
are the I'm speaking to an audience that
is uh probably more aware of what these
do than than than I am uh but uh what we
have uh essentially is a
combination of uh the of uh
macroeconomic models that are based on
um neoclassical Frameworks energy models
that focus on minimization of costs of
abatement vegetation models uh with
Earth system
feedbacks uh coupled with scenario
Frameworks that are essentially
socioeconomic storylines for the future
so you have um you know will there be
sustainable de development will there be
fossil fuel dependence will there be
cooperation or Regional rivalry are the
kinds of story lines that are projected
into the future but uh I think one of
the first issues is that the world in
these models is divided by geographical
regions and this is what we saw
throughout the day as well uh when uh
modeling results were presented which
itself is a problema spoke a little bit
about the problem of risks um and how
they are assessed when this happens but
uh such a distribution doesn't tell us
about differentiated levels of
development production consumption Etc
um when there is an economic
differentiation is only for the oecd so
it's only the oecd that are economies
the rest of us are essentially just
geographies and so that is one issue the
second is of course that irrespective of
storylines that you construct uh the
macroeconomic models that essentially
pursue Pito optimality and uh you know
most of the macroeconomic models follow
this strcture and the negishi Frameworks
that are used freeze income inequalities
uh at current levels not allowing any
more conversions then is considered
reasonable based on historical Trends so
you have inequalities in um these are
results of the ipcc scenarios uh that we
have assessed about 556 scenarios uh
corresponding to the 1.5 and 2° Celsius
temperature targets so you have any
inequalities uh that persist uh across
regions uh even by
[Music]
2050 um these GDP and consumption
figures are of course linked quite
significantly with energy and so you
have energy poverty and energy
inequalities that posist also uh
throughout and this is tied to how
energy demand and Supply are modeled and
coupled with the macroeconomic models
the objective is to minimize the cost of
mitigation so the solution is to find
optimality in terms that are both
spatially and temporally cheaper so you
know if it is cheaper to reduce
emissions through agricultur and
Forestry uh in the developing countries
as compared to say the reduction of oil
gas and coal use in developed countries
that will be the solution and so you
have uh extreme levels of energy
equality inequality persisting across
model scenarios even in the future uh
and the models therefore then end up
projecting much higher levels of
mitigation burdens both in the sh short
and the long term on developing
countries on an average for example
subsaharan Africa is expected to reduce
emissions by 80% in this decade uh
across the scenarios whereas the
reductions are about 50% for Europe and
North America um in line with the ndcs
of these countries right uh the models
also project large amounts of carbon
dioxide removal across models most of
this is coming from the global South um
uh through energy the diversion of land
from
uh food crops to energy crops increasing
the risk of hunger uh across the regions
and so therefore uh the current trend of
decreasing hunger decreasing risk of
hunger is in fact reversed in some of
the more extreme scenarios uh in the
that are assessed by the ipcc in the
future so so the questions of equity
questions of uh the the you know dealing
with questions of vulnerability and risk
which are unequally distributed today
today and remain unequally distributed
even in the future um you know are not
addressed with the with in the current
modeling framework the global South has
denied the means to build resilience
that we've been speaking about
throughout the day and this uh is a
major Gap but there are ways to address
this and maybe we come back to this St
so I'll stop here thank
you I think the three the the the
opening remarks have have really raised
two classes of problems one is the in
some ways you could call it the internal
discussion between groups of experts so
to to what extent are the findings and
the assumptions and not just the
headline but also the guts of the
different models about how humans behave
what are the embedded pieces in the
story what are the assumptions that are
made in order to deliver an estimate of
surface
temperature what are the obstacles to
having a conversation about those
assumptions and whether or not those are
reasonable and whether the inferences
about say human responses to the average
surface temperature are really capturing
human responses to the larger set of
things that are embedded in the model so
one is the conversation between experts
the other is the fact that these
conversations and these models and these
representations
also shape social conversations at
multiple levels so there's the the issue
that tal referred to and I think what
Pierce referred to is and with the use
of the models in informing kind of macro
decisions and the issue that Regina
pointed out which is in some ways the
use of risk information in informing and
in dialogue with at the community
Community level both of these are
important both of these information
flows are important because obviously
the link between what you understand of
environmental change shapes your
response shapes the environmental change
and and forward so you can't really see
these as two isolated issues I think if
would if just for the purpose of
discussion if we could tackle these two
a little bit distinctly because
otherwise we end up with a big sort of
ball of things I guess the first
question is Tony you mentioned having
the conversation and the importance of
having the conversations but in each of
your professional lives where have have
you
found easy ways to have those
conversations have you been
professionally rewarded for having those
conversations and are there ways
to make it easier and more rewarding to
do that if you haven't found that
already what would it take to make make
it a more normal part we can just we can
start with you Tony and work through the
panel okay I think I I think I Ed that
same phrase in my slides that we want to
reward this kind of interaction I think
in general it's quite difficult to
reward that interaction we're kind of
siloed in departments with certain
standards for tenure and and especially
for younger people might be a bit little
bit risky to try to go work with some
climate scientists on our risky project
about building a you know big climate
model that incorporates Earth system
uh richness so I I don't have a
particular answer for how to how to how
to address that I I think somehow that
you know we we need to reward um people
doing this kind of work and and very
often if even within economics you be
across two subfields of Economics
sometimes it can be difficult because
you're talking to two different
audiences sometimes um so I I don't have
a particular answer to that somehow we
need to um recognize in in departments
or in universities that this kind of
work across disciplines is super
important and it may not satisfy
everyone in all the camps but it's it's
it's a new product that no one's ever
seen before and and is offer something
special so I you know it's a question of
what journals you publish in and there's
a whole whole set of issues there um and
in in terms of getting a conversation
started I think that's hard too because
we just don't see each other I think it
was Ken Gillingham who was here earlier
the school of the environment organized
a conference on um getting together
macroeconomists and economists and
climate scientists at the uh up in the
um the school of the environment uh a
few years ago where I where I started
talking to climate scientists and
realizing that I was in over my head a
little bit on my own so I needed to like
learn from them that's how I met Trudy
um and then one thing led to another but
it takes a while to learn how to how to
be comfortable with people and how to
trust people and a in a cooperation so
we had to nurture that relationship for
a while but now it's up and running so
just one question I mean other than that
do you when you look around at other
universities or other academic spaces do
you see an example of something small
that could be scaled up are there um
lighthouses that we could work
from um offand I don't really so much to
be honest
um I I yeah I I I don't I you're looking
for an example of maybe two very
different disciplines someone's working
across them and being successful uh I'm
sure there are but I can't think of any
off hand I know within economics I think
it's a bit of an issue actually uh to be
honest um well we can take that as a
challenge for yell planetary Solutions
we can take that as a challenge I'm not
trying to be I mean maybe I'm too
pessimistic others could uh could
disagree with me but that's kind of the
my my take on it thank you and Regina I
think coming from the um coming from a
different uh discipline um what what has
been your experience with building
projects like my climate risk or some of
these more
interactive uh speaking with decision
makers kinds of projects and um I'll
pass you this
mike um so uh I think you respond to
your previous question a little bit for
our uh as climate scientist the problem
is that we are reward by papers and is a
quantification and not policies I think
we could be as a scientist also be
reward when we in our career for uh
tenure and and we we F to much in the
number of papers that we publish and not
actually uh results of the science
science that could be used for policy
purpose and is a challenge to uh publish
papers in multidisciplinary papers uh
journals that actually accept uh when
you transversal um uh this is also a
challenge and um for us we what the
point that I want to make is that we
generally in our style we we come up
with ideas or or things that we think
that needs to be studied and understand
and we generated this climate um
information and then when you go to uh
to the communities it's not exact what
they need and uh so now in the word clim
research program we we have this kind of
a new activity that we go to the
communities and we needed to talk to
them and then created the information
not try to adjust that information that
we already have in a format that we are
have and then try to kind of push it
down so then is a kind of a bottom up
approach and that's what we are trying
to to to do and have this conversation
with the communities from the beginning
and make it them to be able to then use
that information and even create the
information that they need and be self-
sustained and so may let's see but I
think I just want to highlight one thing
that uh Regina pointed out in the supply
and demand of different scales of
integrated models or different scales of
climate even just
climate impact and risk models in some
ways the whole Enterprise of integrated
assessment models came out of an
expressed demand for an ability to make
a certain kind of decision and I think
there is a broader question when we're
thinking of what is the agenda to build
humans and climate climate in humans we
need to acknowledge a broader set of
demanders and needs that may not be as
visible as macroeconomic National or
state policym and that's a whole other
Challenge and so just to just to flag
that
this research and institutional agenda
for combining the two has multiple sub
areas depending on needs that can be
really quite different not to complicate
things uh back to your Pierce on have
you been rewarded for having the
conversation well I absolutely can have
done I prob the best best example is the
ipcc report on one and a half degrees I
mean this the ipcc terribly
institutionalized and kind siloed
but but just just for this report on one
and a half degrees everything changed
when when we were set a tight timeline
and we had to get all the disciplines
together from the engineers with the con
solutions to the energy experts to The
Climate scienti to the economic expert
to the kind of to the kind of polit to
the kind of political experts we had to
get them all together and and we had to
come up with a kind of report and uh and
it was incredibly Su successful you know
it it sort of kick started the every
every every country trying to get these
Net
Zero targets and and that kind of began
my job in politics but it also inspired
me to set up an
interdisciplinary
Research Center as well where we try and
bring different disciplines together and
and what I find from doing that that is
is it isn't the it it doesn't work for
the old professors but it certainly
works for the younger
generation they don't
particularly particularly can care if
they're climate scientist or or an
economist they sort of just want to
change the world and they sort of want
to want to kind of cherry pick and be
taught the acity to change the world uh
uh and I S of think time is is cating
for all of us too like we have
artificial intelligence on the kind of
Horizon and that could canet change
our disciplines so I just think to be on
the to be on the kind of cutting hedge
we sort of ought to do the can well call
things fun there's the ought to I think
the question is how to how to set up
some of the incentives to do it more
often I mean I think who you're seeing
on this panel here are all people who
have taken the trouble to to do this um
and I I just want to sort of summarize
where we are now before turning it over
to Tel um which is in some ways we have
okay it's hard there are frictions um
just like there are with adaptation but
in some ways if we can you know there's
a there's a willingness there's a good
will there's potentially a um younger
scientists who want to change the world
but then there's also where there's a
pull there's a
response and that research then
generates or potentially could start a
positive cycle um so that leads us I
think into a second set of questions
that we'll come to and how do we
articulate that poll and respond to it
effectively knowing that there are
frictions for doing so in the way that
Sciences are structured um I want to
turn it back to you tel for um just your
thoughts on
rewards and how to increase them for the
kind of work that excavates the
assumptions that you've been looking at
um and yeah your thoughts on what might
make it easier to reduce the
frictions yeah I think um I mean I I
agree with Pierce to to the extent that
you know there is uh definitely a
difference in how uh you know younger
people now my students for example I
have a mix of social scientists and
Engineers uh as students and they work
together and collaborate and uh produce
uh you know work together because the
the the environment in which we do
science uh has changed to a certain
extent and the problem of climate change
I think everybody is recognized it
doesn't uh you know respect disciplinary
boundaries you have to you need to uh
speak across disciplines uh but I think
another issue is that you know while um
ipcc is not just siloed in terms of
uh disciplines but also in terms of
where authors come from I mean
especially if you look at the IM am and
the scenario modeling um it's largely
based in the global North and uh that's
a you know if you talk about global
climate policy that's a huge gap because
you have 82% of the global population
that's very very invested in uh climate
policy making and negotiations and uh
but uh plays very little role in
producing and assessing the science um
be it the natural science or the
physical science or um the social
science that goes into you know the ipcc
reports and that perhaps needs to change
also as uh conversations are changing
with the newer Generations maybe doing
things
differently so just one I mean I think
that that uh raises a really that that
is a good segue into a really important
second set of questions sorry I'm human
so I can't I can't speak to you and have
Tel's face behind me which is why I have
this awkward uh pose here um but I think
that Segways into the second set of
questions which is really how do we
create and articulate not only a demand
for the kind of integrated research to
inform questions that are very present
here and now but also some degree of
discernment and willingness for not
everybody but at least some somebody to
look into the assumptions in ever more
complicated models either climate or
human or
both and to highlight the problematic
ones because I I think that articulation
of demand as well as building of
discernment are two critical features of
cre creating an environment that might
be sufficient to push us over the
frictions to generating a useful set of
knowledge Tel do you have any ideas on
that what might just increase the
discernment and draw more attention to
these assumptions these in other
assumptions um I don't know that's a bit
of a difficult question in the sense
that a lot of uh it depends on what
assumptions we talking about for example
in the in in the climate science uh um
you know domain there might be you might
you deal with a lot of known unknowns
and a lot of unknown unknowns and um as
your understanding are an understanding
of the natural world expands our
computational capacities increase we
perhaps are able to answer questions and
look at assumptions more closely but in
the in the social sciences and
especially when you couple the these
with the Natural Sciences as happens in
the in the modeling domain um it's a the
a lot of the um frictions are
ideological perhaps and also based on
perspectives in terms of where we come
from and the kind of questions that
we're interested in are are those uh in
the you know modeling in the global nor
interested in answering questions of
equity um you know or is it something
that only researchers in the global
South will raise and if they raise will
there be um a will there be capacity to
respond to that demand in the global
South so will you will we be able to
build models for example that don't
trade off Equity against efficiency uh
right that don't don't start with the
with the objective function of
minimizing cost but perhaps start with
the objective function of maximizing
resilience so will will we do we have
the capacity to respond to that demand
even though there is a political demand
to address those kinds of questions so
that I think Still Remains open so it's
not something that you can answer
perhaps in a uniform fashion across
domains in my opinion so I want to ask
you next Regina um for your thoughts I
mean you showed a a nice graph that's
clearly in the public domain and it's in
the ipcc report of where what level of
certainty we have
about relevant climatic conditions in
different areas of the world and made
the point that
underneath some of the um more General
predictions and statements there is a
huge Geographic variation in the origins
of that information that's something
that's out there but it's not widely
known or recognized do you see a space a
way to create more discernment and
demand for evening evening that
out um yes um so what we are trying to
develop in a uh world clim uh research
program now is uh hubs uh local hubs
that they and we can help them to
develop their um information that is
available I'll give it an example
because otherwise so the Met Office of
Brazil doesn't do a good job of uh
deliver a seasonal prediction which is
really important for a agriculture
energy Brazil is hydroelectric 65% so
that's really important for energy
purpose too and uh uh I live in a
Southern Brazil and certainly the
predictions from the Met off for the
whole Brazil and Southern Brazil doesn't
work the global predictions from you
know uh other places also doesn't work
you need a lot of investment in capacity
building and money to run these models
which is not available so what we do is
we get to the local state government uh
a group of a small group of metrologists
and we help them develop simple tools
that they can get this information from
say emergency response my state has a
lot of uh uh extreme events so and then
we are doing this we getting these hubs
around the world um but particularly in
the global sound and help them with
really simple tools that doesn't require
too much money we have the this
information already enough information
available to make them more resilient
and then they learn and they can be
self-sufficient to uh start kind of
producing that clim information that
they need for say whatever uh you know
emergency response for uh extreme events
or I don't don't know
energy Etc
policies just to steal this back from
second so I want to leave um time for
I'm G to come back I want to leave time
for questions from the room and from
Zoom um but just to quickly summarize
and take a poll of the the panelists on
whether we're on the right track in
terms of an agenda for being able to do
this better um if there are two buckets
one is is something to do with
generating greater and more influential
pull for Effective integration
recognizing that that PLL must
be or that agenda setting must be more
Equitable than it has been in the past
and may ask different questions May pose
different challenges for integrated
models so some intervention on the poll
side hoping that the poll help helps
grow efforts to overcome frictions
inspires early career
researchers and perhaps highlights some
of the we don't have a good answer yet
on what would remove the frictions for
bringing the two groups together but
there's a pull side and there's a that
is necessary for unlocking the friction
side that we don't have a good bet for
is that a reasonable two buckets or is
there a third
class of to-do
agenda that I'm missing I do think
that's fine
Jessica up anybody have anything to add
Tel Tony you look like you were about to
to add
them I mean I guess I'm not sure tell
what you mean by a PLL side you mean a a
demand for uh better integrated
assessment models that can address say
distributional issues around the world
inequality somehow so you're looking for
some uh mechanism that would lead more
people to be to to feel like that's a
good Endeavor to engage in their
research is that what you're asking yeah
I mean a pull or a voice an Ask
yeah
but I I should interpret that as really
principally coming from the from the
kind of demand that that is a is such a
demand by Society can
really to give them actionable answers
that work for different countries and
and that is the big kind
of pull as as far as I'm concerned and I
mean uh and I think that pull is really
there and it's really kind of working
it's
very active uh and I think what can what
can what can to what can what can the
teso has been saying it absolutely
correct that I would really love to see
India produce its own i a h and it has
the capacity capacity to do that uh and
I think that I really where we have to
make sure we're challenged by different
expertise and and that the experts in
India have their own expertise that they
can really can bring to we have to be
accepting of the expertise just like the
expertise of inous communities in Brazil
that have their own expertise and we
have to be open to that in in in in
inclusive to
that just myself do have to be inclusive
to The Economist out there that perhaps
people would bit excluded by this
conversation so I'm going including
excluding I think that there's uh I mean
there's clearly a very large agenda to
be to to both be articulated in terms of
what are
the social what what are the questions
that require an understanding of both
the human and social dynamics in order
to make well and then there's a there's
an enormous uh set of tasks on reducing
the frictions I think the good news is
that there are a number of people who
are already involved in that who are
doing it because they see the need and
we are in some ways fumbling toward
doing that better and better I want to
leave the last 15 minutes for questions
from the audience um because I'm seeing
a bunch of hands and twisting um costus
yeah thank you Super H climate models um
and we have less Rich economic models
and I mean it is a c question of cost
benefit let me try a question C where do
you start right so you Tony has like
already read model but what is the
elements that you want to put first a
few elements like heterogeneous agents
or you know like what what cap more
Capital choices or something many
sectors where do you
start I think at least in the economics
literature in the general equilibrium
macro literature I think what's been
missing although it's it's a growing
field now is um looking at at
heterogenity of impacts of climate
change and climate policy around the
world getting it questions of inequality
I think that's just been missing I think
we're starting to build models that
economists all certainly are buying into
to address those questions and I think
one thing that's missing Big Time still
that's why I'm working on it so I tting
my own horn here but I think we pretty
much just are putting an average
temperature uh no weather and just view
doing that as the main variable which it
probably is but I think uh we should be
looking at extreme weather events as
well um putting it putting in weather as
well as climb to the models and
recognizing that weather can impact
locally maybe not it doesn't you know we
get a we don't get a hurricane across
the whole us we get a hurricane locally
so we need to model those somewhat more
local impacts and then study how we can
share those risks across uh across
governments or countries so I think it's
quite important to bring and inequality
that this heterogenea impacts I think
that's pretty well established by now
when I first did my first version of the
model I was like this is crazy how is
coming out um so heterogeneous and I
think weather is just super important
there's some work I think um Rossy
hansburg and bow the paper that U Sam
mentioned earlier is doing some of that
but we need to do much more of that I I
would think that requires bringing in
the richness of Earth system models or
maybe using a a very good emulator that
will let us look at Regional weather
impacts
so I'm not sure if what I'm about to say
is a question or a comment but I felt
like this was so pessimistic compared to
well having you know spent nearly two
years in the White House Science office
and looking at how science was coming
into policy I came away from that
experience being completely odd at least
how much science we were trying to
gobble up and organize and repackage um
and how important it was um and what I
took away was that there's a Missing
Link in the feedback scientists get when
that happens and I think this is part of
the challenge is it's I think we as a
scientific Community have to also think
about like what feedbacks are we
actually expecting because it seemed to
me when I was at the White House like
the most important work was like you
don't site it you let the secretary take
credit for it or you say you know you
let somebody else take it's plagiarism
was actually like I don't want to accuse
the White House of plagiarism but like
you know just poaching stuff was like
that's the really important stuff when
you start studying it's less important
and so I'm wondering just what do we
expect as a scientific community in a
world where we're super unique as
researchers like people read our papers
they site them this is how we evaluate
stuff we look at like exactly we count
but even if you go to like a corporate
world nobody knows exactly anybody's
individual impact and so how we're we're
operating with a world in policy that
like individual impact aren't tracked
and so what are our expectations for
being able to think about how our
science is is responsive to policy and
how we understand that and how we get
those signals
back does anyone have any thoughts on
that I think it's an excellent question
and observation and and I would say that
I've had exactly the same experience
that yeah I do see lots of examples in
my career where it really worked very
well and and should take optimism
from that though but but I've also
through the IC I work in other countries
a lot and I I think in a lot of a lot of
lot of different countries they don't
have the same capacity there and and so
perhaps that is
really something that kind of Tes and
Regina can comment on you said you came
from a particularly bad
partic in Brazil where they completely
ignored
you well um let me just get my thoughts
here um the thing is that uh I think we
have a lot of information for mitigation
purpose what makes me like I think the
uh frustrated is that we know that we
what we have to do but politically in a
high levels we are not having the
engagement this is this is very
upsetting and I I'm not optimistic when
I look into the mitigation aspect and I
know that we already have enough
information that we needed to you know
get to Net Zero Etc but what give me
hope is when I look at you the bottom up
approach that I say which is more this
grassroot process of empow Empower uh
the local community to make sense then
we can build trust we can use that
conversation in a local level you know
but it's not like for scientists that's
sometimes it's not so glorious as the
high level you know scientists when gets
up there they want to just talk to you
know and make uh difference in with
politics and in a high level and uh it's
not like but I I I I see hope in a
Grassroots science doing developing this
so I don't know if I passed this
pessimistic uh but when I think about
the bottom up approach in terms of
climate science with communities then I
think we would change because in this
conversation it can change even how they
vote you know and that what think going
to make much more impact than try to
talk to the politics and changing their
mind Tel did you have anything to add on
this
point
can't hear
you apolog you can't can you hear me now
now we can hear you yeah all right yeah
no so just briefly I mean I
I I'm sorry if I you know I contributed
to the pessimism uh of the message but
uh I don't think it's a you know there
there is a problem in fact in a lot of
developing countries you have far more
uh ready uptake of the signs you have
far less climate Denial in developing
countries uh irrespective of capacities
perhaps scientific in-house scientific
capacities uh there has been much more
adoption uh very clearly of uh climate
policies across regions in the in the
developing World in India for example
you have uh you know agricultural
departments newer crop models coming up
and people working at Regional and uh um
um you know National level model as well
as actually working on the field of you
know trying to experiment and this has
changed remarkably in a very short span
of time uh you know given that we work
in academic uh time spans uh we don't
think uh you know there is a there's
that much of an impact and I agree that
some of this cannot be measured in terms
of Publications and citations um and it
shouldn't be um but unfortunately we are
also uh slaves to our professions and
that's what gets us last tenure for
example so you need to publish and
that's how we end up thinking about
measuring our impact but uh uh it is
true that there is there has been
significant shifts in the way in which
people are thinking uh about the
environment and climate even in
developing countries where you may not
have as much of a footprint uh of the
science as you do uh in developed
countries but uh I think the uh you know
the question for example of what
constitutes the a correct interpretation
of science you know where this entire
focus on Net Zero in the developed
countries is only a partial uh adoption
of what the real science is nobody's
talking about carbon budgets in fact the
UK uh that spoke about carbon budgets
which is in fact the more complete
measure of uh warming um you know went
when it spoke about it in its earlier
plans but has now moved away from it in
in pursuit of Net Zero so you know you
have um um sometimes even science
feeding into it's not just science
providing evidence for policy but policy
telling policy makers telling scientists
what they would like to hear what it is
convenient for them to hear and I think
this goes back to a little bit of the
question that Jessica had about the pull
and push uh right is it always the case
that you have scientists who know the
who who are studying this with all the
uncertainties involved telling policy
makers this is what we have and this is
what is happening or do you also have
now a situation where policy makers know
to a certain extent what the challenges
are and what the issues are but they
also uh know that there's inertia in the
system and they're giving a message to
the scientist that this much is
convenient to us so you do not so don't
amplify the scientific message beyond
that and I I I am a little fearful that
this is what is happening that you have
we are past the era where s scientists
were pushing for certain policies and
you have U you know you have now
scientists being dictated to in terms of
what kind of science to produce and
that's becoming a bit of a problem so we
perhaps need to reverse the trend and
push once again go back to an Era where
we needed to push maybe plurality of
approaches uh welcome uh heterogenity in
terms of uh different approaches and
perspectives in terms of how we do the
modeling thank you
so this has been a go ahead just want to
add a maybe more optimistic point but
first I'll start with a a story about
Nord House's pessimistic very first
version if you read his
biography uh that he put up for the
Nobel Prize the very first version of
his very first climate model was
rejected by all the economics journals
he had to publish it in science but I
think that's this is where now switch to
optim more optimistic I think within
economics there been I think an
explosion of research on climate since I
started working on this 10 years ago or
something I think the pull factor there
might be partly just climate change we
can we can see it really happening it's
like it seems really important and maybe
it didn't seem before also I think
environmental economics is viewed as
more methodologically interesting than
maybe it was before maybe it was unfair
to environmental economics but be seeing
like you can use all these modern tools
from other IO or from micro and bring
them in bring them here I where I'm a
little more pessimistic is whether you
can convince economists to get actively
involved in the policy world because
don't reward that for tenure and then
working across the so economists are
maybe happy with their models but then I
find skepticism from sociologists or
maybe climate scientists about what I'm
doing so I you know to really have
influence in in in the broader world you
kind of want to confront you know you
kind of you need to talk to other types
of social sciences that scientists and I
I think that's not rewarded so
much so I just I'm getting the the flag
that we're at the end of our time but I
just wanted to flag that that that this
particular interaction is actually a an
environmental social feedback loop that
we don't know that much about and sort
of proves the point of the panel how do
we tell better structured informative
stories about how to amplify exactly
this Loop between seeing the change
being more excited about about it having
more conversations this isn't humans and
climate models and climate and human
models but this is the kind of
conversation that we need to figure out
how to represent understand and amplify
so we'll leave it on that optimistic
note and uh that uh to-do list for all
of us and head into the reception and
dinner um the panel will be around um
and Tel thank you so much for joining us
I hope you do get some sleep and we'll
be following up if you have questions
for Tel I think just let me know and we
can convey them to Tel and and hopefully
build something from this panel to
amplify the interaction thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you